I want to play a game called quack or
whack cracker wag let's go if you're
down you say quack if you're not into it
it's whack okay real quick your own
reality spin-off quack I do a lot of
mission work I go over to different
countries and I would love for a reality
show on that because I would love to
educate people in America on what's
actually happening around the world sexy
selfies on Instagram as you get older if
a magazine approaches you to do maybe a
sexy photo shoot I think that people my
fan base essentially they support me
because I've shown myself in the rather
more classy way Dancing with the Stars
all-star season quack major quiet go oh
my god Widmark again uh yeah it would
have to be with your political
aspirations would you ever take a role
in office quack I would I would love
that but we actually just went to DC and
took some classes from senators to teach
me just like more things but if you're
if you're gonna be out in the spotlight
if you're gonna be leading in some
capacity might as well be leading in the
right direction
totally is there one issue that you
would really want to tackle foreign aid
because that's what I do around the
world and I try to help our brothers and
sisters in different countries tattoos
and piercings
quacks maybe more weird unless it's like
a word like fearless at my life it
changed from a lot of girls your age are
tackling this idea of altering
themselves whether it's lip injections
or a little Botox here they're quack or
whack people can do whatever they want
with their body but I do hope that they
knows how alike they are beautiful it
just has this it's kinda like you do you
girls right you do you I hope that your
heart is carrying it yeah do it to make
yourself feel better yeah yeah